Uh, wow. We have a lot of people that are
holding and trying to get on. What area code
should we go to? I mean, there's just so many
here to pick from. Uh, let's go to, I don't
know, let's try the eight, five, seven area
code. Who's calling today from eight five,
seven.
Hey David. How are you doing?
Good. Who's this?
I'm Eddie from Boston.
Hey Eddie. We're in Boston. Are you?
Yeah.
Oh, I'm, I'm from lots. Very born and raised,
but I live in Madison right now.
Okay. Very good. What's on your mind?
All right, cool. My quick question is with
this political climate right now, um,
yeah,
what's up with everybody? You voted against
their own interests as far as uh, econ economically
they own interest versus with the feel of,
I guess I would label that as emotional politics.
Here's what is often missing. So I've talked
about this a lot and recently my thinking
has evolved on it. Uh, go back to the tea
party, right? The Tea Party in 2010, right.
They all came out and they're advocating policies
of cutting taxes for the rich and all sorts
of economic policies that statistically will
never benefit them. They're not going to be
rich. Maybe right out of one of the 10,000
rule doesn't make any sense. Here's what we
need to understand to understand their motivation.
And Jonathan Heit wrote about this like 10
years ago. Okay. They are voting in the best
interests of what they perceive to be their
in group. So even though, yes, we look at
it, yeah, they make 30 grand a year. Why do
they want to cut taxes for people making over
500 k a year doesn't make any sense. They
identify
one of my main things. I completely blows
my mind. I'm like, yeah, and,
and what we have to understand, the left is
they have identified, it's not so much a tribe,
but it's groupish snus to avoid the term tribalism.
There group wants that. So they are voting
for it because they perceive that it is good
for their group in total, even if it's unlikely
to benefit them personally. That that's what
we have to understand.
Okay. I, you know, yes, I live in massive
bosses. I make, I would make a lot of money.
I consider myself above average middle class.
I am black on top of all that. So it's, it's,
I sit back and I listened to my coworker speak
about, you know, I'm like, okay, I know you're
not doing economically to better or just better
than me. So how do you guys go out and vote
for these people that don't care about your
wellbeing and just kind of have this covered
his mind blown
at the end. There's no reason, you know how
like with a beehive, the, the bee itself is
not like the, the entity or the unit, it's
the hive. And one B does is not necessarily
for the benefit of the B. It's for the benefit
of the hive, whether it's a worker or they're
pollinating or a drone or whatever. What you
have to understand is that a lot of these
political preferences are based not necessarily
on what is actually good for the individual.
It's what has been adopted as the sort of,
uh, an orthodoxy of what is perceived as the
political group. And that's why you get people
voting in ways that don't seem to align with
their position economically.
Yeah.
You know, coming from where we come from,
David, specifically in Massachusetts, you
know, we have a melting pot of everybody,
everything and you know, viewing for the rest
of the country and what they go through on
a daily basis of, I'm a, I'm gonna say specifically
the south or the Midwest and the racism and,
um, money equality and stuff like that. And
you would think with, with general common
sense basis that people would honestly do
what's best for the interest. And I'm not
saying that you have to be a less leftists.
I'm not saying that you have to be a liberal,
I'm not seeing none of that stuff, but whatever
benefits you as a person in benefits your
family and whatever makes you make more money
and take care of your responsibilities better
as a, as a man was a person, why would you
go against that?
Yep. Got It. Thank you for your time allocated
dynamics that explain it. All right, Eddie,
great to talk to you. Appreciate the follow
up phone call. Always great to hear from are
a Boston based viewers. Uh, okay. I'm out
of topic. I will. Oh, and he decided that
we have that strange delay.
Sorry, Eddie. Eddie, I think he was about
to say he had been following the show for
what I'm sure is a very flattering amount
of time. Okay. I'm out of time. That's it
for today. We will take calls again.